hey everybody welcome back to planet
coaster in this video I'm going to make
one building which is a little bit
underwhelming but it's a very important
building because it's going to be the
reference for a lot of what follows in
this area the reason for that is maybe a
bit complicated to explain but I'll try
it anyway so basically what I want to do
with this park most importantly is focus
a lot on the detail and making new kind
of realistic details with the pieces
that we have in the game so far and not
make any grandiose or impressive things
and really just keep it on the small
scale things and try to make new stuff
like new rides like new elements for
buildings and really make that the main
focus and especially in this Dutch
setting it felt like a really important
thing to think about but is looking at
it
there aren't any details there aren't
any textures or anything remotely touch
in the pieces of the game so far
but the theme also feels different from
other themes that we have because it's
actually uses many of those standard
textures in the game and doesn't really
use any particular shapes that you don't
find in other types of buildings say
styles like Japanese have a lot of like
very particular building structures but
if you just take away all of the details
on the Dutch building you just end up
with a very generic brick building that
could be anywhere and that's why I
wanted to really use this building as a
place to mess around with detailing to
get those really typical touch things in
and make sure that those are good before
I head into the other buildings which
will more or less most likely be based
on this so I'll go through all of the
different details that I wanted to get
into this building to make it look as
such as I can throughout this video
basically the very basic build up of the
building is very simple it's partly
inspired by a small inner-city castle in
Arnhem the devil's house I think it's
called it's also partly inspired by any
gable house in the Netherlands and
another part of the inspiration was just
winging it and see where I ended up
but about the detailing that's where
most of the important stuff is happening
so one thing that I really wanted to get
in as much as I could here and what I
actually wanted to change the layout of
the building a bit for as well just to
make sure I could get a few of these in
is a stepped gable of course many Dutch
buildings are really famous for their
Gables those clock gables or stepped
gables those strange facades that you
see in all of the buildings in Amsterdam
and it's one thing that I wanted to get
in quite a lot here so I wanted to get a
stepped gable on the front of the
building on the side of the building and
who is thinking for a while I could also
get a steps gable dormer in but that
didn't turn out to be very good planning
and so I'm making that at the moment and
you can see I'm also adding these
horizontal light lines on the bricks and
that's one thing that I tried to look up
the translation for and try to see if
there is any other countries in the
world that actually do it but I haven't
been able to find them in Dutch they
would literally be called layers of fats
and I am not sure if it really
translates into anything English that
actually makes sense but they're
basically these thin layers of any kind
of lighter material in between the brick
and in this case I'm using their wooden
light brackets just to get that sort of
page is each colour in and you see them
on many touch tables and many touch
facades and they're just sort of like a
decoration
that's horizontally spread over the
entire building I think they started
doing that somewhere in the rainiest in
the Renaissance or renascence whatever
you want to call it and the one thing
that I really wanted to get into many of
these buildings here is the typical sort
of touch detail and another thing is
actually in the windows which is very
subtle and something that maybe I should
have mentioned before but you see many
of these windows in the Netherlands
which have these like these cross frames
you just have the frame outside of the
window but inside of that you have a
white frame in
the shape of a cross more or less and
that's all I want is getting many of
these winners as well because I'm pretty
sure it's a very common thing in many
Dutch buildings so you can already see
all of the layers of bacon and all of
the stepped gables and the cross framed
windows on the sides here so that's the
most important stuff done and mostly
like characteristic pieces of this
building done a bit of making things a
little bit more neat on the side here by
adding that small trim to the roof
thinking a roof trims are is something
that I just always like adding a very
simple to add but just make everything a
little bit more neat especially if the
transition between the boars and the
roof isn't going all that smoothly
otherwise and on top of that little
archway which was inspired by the castle
in einem I wanted to get a bit of
decoration as well I was figuring for a
while I could get some battlements in
there which would make the building look
quite cozy but um ended up just going
for a very simple border there I'm not
entirely sure what it's supposed to be
but figured it would look good and
pretty much work and another thing that
should finish off the very basic walls
here is a quick foundation wall around
the entire thing and filling that up
that is pretty much the base of the
building now it is time to move into the
rest of the building adding a few more
layers of fat over here which it is
quite narrow there isn't too much fat on
this building there's just a couple of
layers outside of the facade I didn't
want to overdo it you do see many
buildings in the Netherlands which have
these white layers pretty much from top
to bottom everywhere but especially
since this one is a bit more wide and
visible with the wooden brackets being a
little bit larger than I was hoping for
I wanted to not use too many of these
and on the side here I wanted to use
them as a sort of way to imitate corner
stones though you only really see them
on the facade part of the building so
they won't be added to the sides of the
building it's just a nice way to give
the side of the front here a bit of a
accent with this color as well
one of the things that has been kind of
making me so far is just the lack of
wall textures so far in alpha 2 and 1
most of the textures are definitely
really good especially at this point you
just see this brick texture over and
over again and it's one thing that makes
all of these buildings look really
similar so try to cover the brick
texture up a little bit here by adding
all of these bacon bits that word still
doesn't make any sense
anyway the windows in this building are
all slightly different one of the thing
one of the reasons why I wanted to do
that is I wouldn't have different
windows on the 1st and the 2nd floor
that's one reason and I also needed
different windows in the middle of the
building and on the side of the building
is the middle of the building or I
should say the front of the building in
this unlit building this the broad of
the building has these cornerstones
while the side of the building doesn't
have any so that's where I can pretty
much Center my windows in the center of
a tile but I can't really do it here and
all of these windows are just the your
very typical Dutch window kind of thing
they just have a white frame with a
white cross in the middle of it maybe a
few more decorations here and there with
a small fancy stone arch but aside from
that they pretty much all follow the
same formula just have very small
variations on that and the small arch
over here which I don't actually know if
those things have a name you just see
many of these light stone arches on top
of many doors and windows in the
Netherlands so I wanted to add that very
quickly there and finally finishing the
frame of the window which at first I
wanted to do with some white frames much
like just about every window in the
Netherlands but I ended up going with
brown frames on the side which is a very
unusual thing I might change it at some
point in time but the same that goes for
the brick wall kind of goes for these
concrete pieces as well I feel or render
I think it is it's just a sort of a
tiring texture especially after seeing
it every single time for a few months
now in alpha 2 it's just the same
texture over
over again and it's very light it
doesn't really have much contrast going
on there which is why for a change I
wanted to add the brown sides there and
not have the entire thing be so very
radiating White's color but for the rest
of these winner is actually chose to go
with a different approach which actually
it works quite well similar to what I've
done before adding just the white frames
I wanted to add before and after that
add some well accents to it in a
slightly different color so here I'm
adding the sign of the carousel just to
add a very thin line of brown on these
white frames which doesn't make too much
of an impact but it does kind of give a
bit of the illusion of shadow or
slightly different textures and at the
very least it makes the windows pop out
a bit less because they the whites
really contrasts a bit too much mainly
with the brick walls behind them and the
same goes for the very last windows on
this side of the building here because I
still needed some different windows on
the side of this building since I needed
one that is centered inside a tile but
it's pretty much the same as the other
windows so far just a slightly different
shape to it it's not exactly square and
I don't think any of these windows are
exactly squares it's a little bit taller
than it is wide since I'm pretty sure if
you add two of these windows together
yeah you just have four squares so
that's one big square window the one
thing that's kind of awkward about these
things is that the middle frame isn't
entirely across and I would like to see
these things being across but in the end
I just wanted to cover up the black
frames of the in-game window for which I
needed to get those while the white
frames in like this just to cover up
those black frames so it's not the most
realistic Dutch frame because I don't
necessarily need these double beams in
the middle of the window it's just one
quirk that I needed to get in to cover
up what the in-game window has so that's
just about it for some of the windows
just covering up a bit of the roof here
because I did accidentally spill a bit
of my scenery items onto the roof
which isn't very good and had to cover
that up for a second here and the next
thing that I wanted to move on to after
that and a bit more detailing on the
roof as well
is adding some other final touches to
the building before I move into the
restaurant part because it is going to
be a restaurant in the end so what I
wanted to do first is add a nice little
cover on the front which isn't
particularly a touch thing to do it's
just what I figured it would look nice
and actually add some pillars as well to
these arches here I drew a figure this
is a bit of a light touch relations kind
of building and these pillars or these
arches I should say we're looking very
narrow they don't really look like they
could hold up a lot of weight and I
wanted to add a bit of thickness to them
by any of these pillars here which is
mainly what this strange window thing is
here to do so adding those pillars in
there just to give there was a bit more
strength to them as well now I always I
think these wooden posts here just to
have them connect to the top
I figured it would be a better
transition than just having these
pillars go to the top of this thing and
there's no way to really get any kind of
good crown to these pillars that
actually fits with the textures here and
of course I couldn't help myself but
actually place some planters in front of
the windows as well put a few windows on
the bottom of the building here before
this entire thing turns into an area
with tables and chairs and I'm not
really able to reach that place anymore
and it's pretty much time to start work
on the restaurant and for a while here I
was trying to get some tables and chairs
in from other places in the park where I
already made tables and chairs but that
lazy approach didn't really work out
well because obviously I have this
little raised brick thing here and the
height on the most Millie crates and
also they seemed like a very good
opportunity to actually try and make
some new tables so I ended up going with
some tables that are made out of the
yeah a little pirate decoration thing
which works quite nice with that trick
of just rotating something around that
sky storm came up with which is really
handy if you're looking for these like
smaller details and
you don't really notice that any
textural things are well going wrong I
would usually say that it's kind of
dangerous to go and use that glitch or
go and use that trick to rotate stuff
around because you do end up getting a
lot of Polly's at one time but um since
these things are pretty much your splats
feel pretty safe making these tables
like these so a few custom tables in
here a few custom chairs on the side of
these tables which are pretty much the
chairs that I've used throughout the
rest of this park already and that
should be most of what the restaurant is
going to be I was thinking for a while
to maybe at these the wooden parasols
that I made earlier on in the park and
add them to these tables but they ended
up not really looking that great
especially since I've already used the
word a few times already and it just
doesn't really fit the Dutch theme I
think it looks a little bit too flimsy
for it
so ended up just removing those parasols
even adding a little stone pillar to it
couldn't really work out and just use
the large square parasols instead which
I kind of do wish I could have a nice
modern texture too but this will do the
job anyway
now for something a bit fancier which is
going to make this building look a bit
more fancy and expensive than a very
simple little townhouse are these large
arched windows that I wanted to add on
the bottom on the side here because this
side of the building is like it's taller
than your average base floor but it's a
little bit too short to actually have
two floors underneath it so I figured I
could go for some very nice very tall
arched windows and that's why I ended up
going forward with this kind of simple
window again just a white cross frame
around it and a piece that I haven't
used in quite a long time to just get an
arch on top of it that should basically
be the simple decoration along the side
of that part of the building
I'm leaving one part empty here because
I will add another roof on the back of
the building just to give it a bit more
depth
because at the moment it's a very narrow
building and not necessarily one that
you would think you could fit an entire
restaurant in so we'll see and yeah get
something in there at some point in the
future but first I also needed to make a
door and this one is quite a bit wider
actually had a comments a while ago
about some of the restaurants in this
park many of the restaurants would look
like they're just menu restaurants with
either one or two very small entrances
and I haven't really had anything so far
that is really opened and I wanted to
make this quite a bit more open also so
it could kind of look like it could be
one of these self-service restaurants
especially since it is already quite
close to the other restaurants out there
so I'm adding a very large more open
door on the back of the building the
front door which is on the part that
sticks out is a bit more traditional and
less modern and a bit less efficient as
well and this door at least should be
able to keep the entrance into this
building quite wide and well yeah the
last part of this building is that point
at the end which sticks out here which
is not there for any kind of aesthetic
purposes it's just there to make this
building a bit bigger make sure that you
can actually fit a restaurant inside of
this little building so nothing to see
there basically didn't want to add a few
windows to it to at least make it look
like a decent backstage area but that's
basically it's not the last thing that I
wanted to do because the building at
this point is almost finished is at a
bit of a gable to it or well he has just
add a gable to it and a chimney now the
gable was actually something that I was
having some troubles with for quite a
while there aren't too many typical
Dutch Gables but they do have shapes
that just kind of don't really work that
well with the pieces in the game so far
so what I ended up going with is just a
very simple gable just a simple roof on
the front with a like-new little trick
to get the roof pieces in which actually
works better than I expected and might
it should be something that I
a bit more in the future but anyway
they'll just have to do a simple roof
pieces here so adding them in there and
finally the white frame around the
window and a small little pointy bits on
the front of the window to at least make
it look a little bit more fancy same
goes for these decorations on the side
kind of make it look almost like it's
one of these large decorated Gables
facades and that is pretty much the
building itself now all that's left to
do is add a bit of detail to it in well
other buildings basically quick chimney
a bit of an accent alongside what is the
floor of the restaurant the table
section and a bit of foliage around it
which was mostly done to actually get
the thumbnail of this video and made
sure that it doesn't just look like a
house in the middle of nowhere so a few
plants in there and also a fence to
fence it all off I will get some kind of
gates probably to actually get a gate
into this area at some point in time but
I'm not really sure when that's actually
gonna happen but until then this is what
this part of the park looks like few
final touches couple of lanterns on top
of tables and a couple of lanterns on
the side of the building along with a
restaurant esque sign and an expert and
an extra table and that should do it and
that's it for the time map section so
I'm gonna give it over to my real self
here so let's have a quick good look at
this building before we get into the
next episode it is a really small
building as you can see in the end and
it's just a very small almost eye shaped
footprint just two meters or two tiles
wide on most places and pretty much
surrounded by all of the tables most of
the layout of the building is just there
not really to look good but to kind of
fit into the area in general this is a
very new area so I wanted to keep it
very open and kind of for a similar
reason I've replaced the octopus over
here with African what they call it's
here the insanity well it sure is but um
I think it fits in a bit better how's
that square-ish footprint which should
help to get some bill
in behind this to sort of close the area
after this ride and in between these
rights and the restaurant and everything
it is still going to be quite open so I
will fill these spaces with some bushes
and things like that but it definitely
won't be very busy and for that the
restaurant is just kind of a really
visible part of the area as well and
just one then I think in the end sits
quite nicely over there especially as
you enter it and it's one of the first
things on your right side there and it
kind of opens up and you see the roller
coaster tracks there that's why I kind
of like about the layout of this section
of the park it also flows quite well I
think I probably I probably in hindsight
should have made this circle a little
bit smaller around the pillar here but
aside from that I'm quite happy with the
general layout so what I'll do basically
is have some sort of ring ish building
around this it's not going to be
anything large to close this off get
into the detail around the entire area
which is mostly going to be part of
elements and foliage and then get into
this part of the park which I will
definitely smooth out the terrain I just
wanted to move it outward a bit because
since this is the Dutch area I do wanna
keep this quite flat anyway that's it
for today so thank you guys for watching
and I hope to see you guys next time